in the last video we were able to set up
this definite integral using the shell
or the hollow cylinder method in order
to figure out the volume of this solid
of revolution and so now let's just
evaluate to this thing and really the
main thing we have to do here is just to
multiply what we have here out so
multiply this expression out so this is
going to be equal to I'll take the two
pi out of the integral
two pi is times the integral from 0 to 1
c2 times square root of x is 2 I'll
write it as 2 square roots of X but all
right it's 2 X to the one-half it'll
make it a little bit easier to take the
antiderivative conceptually or at least
in our brain so 2 times square root of X
is 2x to the 1/2 2 times negative x
squared is negative 2x squared and then
we have negative x times the square root
of x well that's X to the first times X
to the 1/2 that's going to be negative x
to the three-halves power and then we
have negative x times negative x squared
that's going to be positive x to the
third power and all of that DX and so
now we're ready to take the
antiderivative so this is going to be
equal to 2 pi times the antiderivative
of all of this business evaluated at 1
and at 0 so the antiderivative of 2
times X to the 1/2 is going to be 2 it's
going to be C we're going to take X to
the 3 halves times 2/3 so it's going to
be 4/3 X to the 3 halves and then for
this term right over here it's going to
be negative 2/3 X to the 3rd negative
2/3 X to the third and you can take the
derivative here to verify that you
actually do get this and then right over
here see if we increment to this you get
X to the 5 halves and so we're going to
wanted to multiply by 2/5 so - let me
just in another color let's say so this
one right over here it's going to be
minus 2/5 minus 2/5 X to the 5 halves
power let me yep that works out and then
finally you're going to have X to the
4th over 4 plus I'm going
in color plus X to the fourth plus X to
the fourth over four that's this term
right over here and now we just have to
evaluate it one and zero and zero
luckily all of these terms end up being
a zero so that that's nice and cancels
out and so we're just left with we're
just lowered and canceled out it just
evaluates to zero so this is just 2 pi
times when you evaluate all of this
business at one so that's going to be
4/3 minus 2/3 minus 2/3 minus 2/5 minus
2/5 plus 1/4 plus 1/4 and the least
common multiple right over here looks
like 60 so we're going to want to put
all of this over denominator of 60 so
it's going to be 2 pi times all of this
business over a denominator of 60 and
4/3 is the same thing as 80 over 60
negative 2/3 is the same thing as
negative 40 over 60 negative 2/5 is the
same thing as negative 24 over 60 and
then 1/4 is the same thing as 15 over 60
so this is equal to and actually this
will cancel over here and you just get a
30 inner denominator so in your
denominator you get a 30 and up here 80
minus 40 is 40 40 minus 24 gets us to 16
16 plus 15 is 31 so we get 31 times pi
over 30 for the volume of the figure
right over there